il y a 62 % des jeunes qui ont déjà
regardé un film porno avant l'âge de 16
ans or la moyenne du premier rapport
sexuel et de 17 ans regardez du porno à
partir du moment où il est éthique et
voilà où les gens sont bien traités
c'est absolument pas un problème par
contre ce qui est important c'est de se
rappeler que le porno c'est pas la vraie
vie
[Musique]
l'apparence physique dans les films
porno elle est quand même très
stéréotypée un pénis en moyenne fait
entre 13 et 15 cm en érection et donc du
coup c'est quand même très peu les sexes
qu'on voit dans les films porno et puis
on rappelle que l'élève des vulves
peuvent être asymétriques différemment
coloré il y en a des plus foncés que
d'autres etc et nous on voit quand même
assez régulièrement bah voilà des
petites vulves bien lisses et puis des
pénis quand même très protubérant quoi
donc ça peut créer des complexes bien
avant d'avoir entamé sa vraie vie
sexuelle
[Musique]
l'orgasme avec un grand o il est plutôt
facile mécanique et très bruyant donc
quand même pas mal de pornos alors que
dans la vraie vie c'est beaucoup plus
complexe que ça ça n'est pas mécanique
d'ailleurs pour personne qu'on a un
pénis ou pas il se passe quand même des
choses entre le cerveau et le plaisir
l'excitation sexuelle
[Musique]
dans les films porno il y a un énorme
focus sur la pratique de la pénétration
tout est très phalocentré on a à peu
près 90% du film qui est tourné autour
de la pénétration soit vaginale soit
anale du coup dans l'imaginaire
collectif on peut avoir une pénétration
super longue sans aucun problème etc or
la moyenne d'un rapport sexuel
pénétratif et de 5,4 minutes c'est hyper
important qu'on ait les chiffres en
thème pour se tranquilliser avec la
durée du rapport sexuel pénétratif et
c'est peut-être l'occasion d'aller
explorer tout le reste du corps en
dehors de la génitalité parce que il y a
plein d'autres zones érogènes qui
peuvent être stimulées qui peuvent être
hyper chouettes en gros il y a pas que
la pénétration dans la vie sexuelle
[Musique]
dans le porno on voit très peu
l'utilisation de lubrifiant et souvent
l'utilisation de la salive les
participants les acteurs vont cracher
dans leurs mains sur le sexe de leur
partenaire et donc on va aussi pouvoir
s'imaginer que ça a un pouvoir
lubrification en fait il y a des enzymes
dans la salive qui vont assécher les
muqueuses qui vont faire qu'on est
irrité qui dit irritation frottement
pénétratif et là on a des lésions il y a
un grand risque de transmission des
infections sexuellement transmissibles
et en plus le rapport sexuel n'est pas
confortable donc on a tout à gagner à
utiliser du lubrifiant à la place de la
salive
[Musique]
dans les films porno parfois c'est un
peu le cirque Pinder du cul enfin
c'est-à-dire que vraiment les gens voilà
sont là pour faire des performances
déroulades des triples sauterieux alors
que dans la vraie sexualité ben en fait
parfois des gens on a une sexualité très
tranquille très romantique hyper
épanouissante et quand on va regarder du
porno classique on va se trouver quand
même vraiment en décalage avec ce qu'on
peut voir et les pratiques qui sont en
fait plutôt très chouettes quand on les
apprécie mais en fait pas obligatoire
dans sa sexualité je pense notamment à
la pratique de l'anal qui quand même
présente dans énormément de films porno
or on sait que seul un Français sur deux
a déjà testé la pratique de la nalle et
que très peu en fait le pratique
fréquemment une autre pratique dont on
entend énormément parler sur lesquels je
suis très sollicitée c'est les émissions
fontaines une émission fontaine c'est
une émission importante de liquide
expulsé par l'urètre lors d'un moment de
grande excitation sexuel spoiler alert
ce liquide c'est de l'urine mais c'est
quelque chose qu'on peut lire dans très
peu d'endroits parce que le porno tend à
aseptiser la sexualité dans la pratique
c'est pas si courant que ça c'est pas si
simple d'obtenir une émission fontaine
et c'est surtout un petit peu sur côté
au niveau du plaisir